what is it with guys immediately coming on to dating apps and starting off like
very vulgar and sexual
and like don't say it's because I'm fat because I know that my like
thin friends like
also received this
and just like
what happened to like charm
you know what happened to like class
what happened to
I don't know flirting
like I just like
why do men feel as other entitled to people's bodies
like I just don't understand how we got to this point of like
sexual liberation
we're like
women are being treated as objects again um
and you know
men are treating whoever they want as objects for their own sexual gratification
like I'm sorry
there's nothing like
liberating or respectful
or desirable about a man thinking that
the first message they send a person should be inherently sexual and
like degrading in nature
it like
I don't deny that this is probably exasturated because I'm fat
I don't deny that literally in the slightest
however I know that my thin friends also experience this and also have like
inherently very sexual and like
do meeting messages as like
openers on dating apps
and I just don't think that like
that is something that we should be allowing
I don't know I'm not like a brood
I really am not
but like what
I just got a message
oh my god like
that's your opener
are you insane
have you ever spoken to a human being ever before
like literally all of my friends who date men have experienced the same thing
and so I know it's not just a
like me being fat thing
like I know that for a fact
I just like
don't understand why this is behavior has become normalized
like I
I don't know like
also just like
not as fun right
like like
I'm sorry but I'm not gonna lie
I think a big part of like
the fun is the like tension
it's the like
will they won't they
it's the getting to know each other's
the flirting it's the like
I don't know it's the process of getting there
and then just now we live in a world where it's like oh
you know you imagine a dating app and immediately you're just gonna have sex
it's like
controversial
no like
what if we had a conversation for us
what if you know
you spoke to a human being
I don't know I don't think it's much to ask
I really don't think it's much to ask
I don't think I asked for much
and I think most of us don't ask for much
I just think it's degrading